What are the best ways of police officer
can condition themselves to violence
and confrontation? I currently
train Jujitsu, but I'm not. I am,
but I am curious what else I can do
to keep myself and others safe from
unpredictable violence.
This is not a self defense question or
either mental conditioning question.
Very cool question.
Uh,
appreciate that question because this
individual recognizes that there is a
little bit more to it than
just the physical self defense.
Then that's the mental and
he's 100% right. So here's
some things that you can do
when you get the opportunity. You've got
to get some realistic training going.
And I've talked about it a little bit
on here with the kind of realistic
training that we did in the seal teams.
There's things that up
the intensity greatly.
Simunition or uh,
like a paintball scenario.
Another good thing is
getting, uh, you know,
really heavy sparring equipment
on. So face gear, you know,
and really go to town.
We are trying to attack someone
and take them down and do it,
you know, three on one, four on one.
Gotta be careful not to get hurt.
You don't want to go that extreme. But
if someone puts on headgear, you know,
with a face mask and the whole nine yards,
shin guards in padded outfit on and people
can attack them and you have to react
to it. The other good thing to do is
do it in a situation where you know,
you don't let the guy know
what's going to happen.
You know he's gotta keep his eyes closed
until you say go. And he opens his eyes.
There's someone there with a knife
right in front of a fake knife,
right in front of him is going to stab
him and he's got to draw his weapon and
shoot or defend himself somehow.
So you want to hit him with these
unexpected drills, with your weapons,
without your weapons shooting and moving.
So those are,
those are the kinds of things.
As soon as you get the opportunity
to do it and it's even good. I mean,
if you've been in a, in a, in a,
you know, shooting drill with like a
barricaded shooter, which is, you know,
you put a shooter or the end
of a hallway and he's hidden,
but he shooting at you with
paint ball and you get,
you can get the intensity up very high.
It's getting shot with paintball hurts.
And if you're getting nailed and you've
got to do something, and people are like,
I gotta make a call, go do something.
You've got to make it happen.
How are you gonna stop this guy?
You can get your intensity up
and you can get used to that.
You can inoculate yourself somewhat to
that stress and learn to detach yourself
from it and not let it affect
you and not let it grind on you.
So that's the realistic
training. And, and honestly, I,
when I watch some of the police
videos of the bad shootings,
now we know police officers throughout
the country every day are under a burden
of hostility.
And they do an outstanding job over
and over again making great arrests and
helping people and saving people that are
suicidal, incredible amount of things,
right? Of course, no one releases
those videos and they don't go viral.
The videos that go viral and the videos
that people watch or the bad ones,
the bad ones,
the bad ones.
And I hope that the police departments
across America are doing something to
inoculate their troopers from the stress
cause that when I watch these videos,
that is what I see happening.
The,
the stress level and the,
the inexperience of the
stressful situation.
And there's one video that
I watched which is awful,
and the guy gets a call,
uh, you see as you see his,
the first thing you see it,
the whole thing is a body camera.
And forgive me if someone
pulls this video up,
and I'm not a hundred percent accurate,
but he gets a call,
it's at a seven 11 guy with a
gun guy pulls a new seven 11.
The cop pulls into the
seven 11 as he's getting,
he gets out of his car and he sees a
guy kind of walk in one direction out of
the seven 11 and turn and walk into
another direction. Guys got a Hoodie on.
He's walking away so the cop
gets out, he's yelling at
him, Hey, stop, stop, stop.
That guy doesn't stop.
Finally he's,
he's now approaching him and
he's standing in the open,
and this is something that I see in
a lot of these videos. These cops,
they stand in the open when if you
imagine that the other guy has a gun,
why would you stand in the open?
Take cover, you take cover.
That's the first thing you do.
If you're,
even if you're trying to stop
somebody or trying to yell at someone,
you take cover.
So if they turn around and have a gun,
you only have a small portion of your
body exposed and you don't get scared
because you're hanging out in
the open. So yeah. So anyways,
this guy is approaching, he's standing
out in the open, he's yelling at the guy.
Finally the guy turns around.
And when the guy turns around,
he reaches in his jacket and boom,
the cop shoots him,
the guy falls down,
he kind of rolls into a curb,
the cop comes over.
As soon as the cop comes over,
you very quickly realize what's going on.
And that is that the guy had headphones
on underneath his hoodie and he couldn't
hear the cop yelling at him.
And then as the cop searches him,
he pulls out of his pocket, his iPhone.
And so he was just listening to music,
reached in his pocket to uh, turn it
off, turn it off, and he got shot.
Horrible situation.
So how do you inoculate yourself to that?
You've got to put yourself into training
situations where you do have the
instinct to take cover.
Will you do have the instinct
to see what people's hands are?
We do have the instinct to realize that
you put yourself in a better situation
where if the guy does pull out a gun,
you have time to react to it and you
can react to it from a safer distance,
you know, as a, so there's a lot
of things I would love to, uh,
start to, and I don't know how,
you know, I don't know how, um,
I don't know how to go about this,
but I would love to start working with
police departments in some manner to get
some training setup. Like the
training we had in the seal teams,
which was the training that I sit
up in the seal teams was psychotic.
How stressful we would make it so
that these guys were overwhelmed.
They were as explosions, machine,
gunfire, paint balls, hitting them, uh,
smoke everywhere, screaming, civilians,
screaming wounded, uh, actors.
We'd hire actors that were amputees. They
have blood spurting all over the place.
It was incredibly realistic.
And that way when guys got into combat,
like one of the first time I ever
got shot and I was like, okay,
here's what's going on.
So I hope at some point I can,
I can help the military with that.
Now in addition to that,
as you're trying to knock yourself your
to this violence and get used to this,
watch those youtube videos,
watch those youtube videos of street
fights of stupid encounters with,
with bars,
with drunk people and bouncers with uh,
the shoot or don't shoot
scenarios with cops,
military situations where they have
helmet cams on and you can see things
happening.
And what you want to do is you want to
watch those videos and you want to pay
attention to the people,
to the humans and watch the reactions
and watch their movements and watch their
body language and watch their expressions
on their faces and see and judge and
predict and go to another
video and hit pause and say,
this is what I see right here.
This is what I think is about to happen.
And educate yourself on human nature
because human nature is what you're going
to be dealing with.
And violence is a part of human nature.
And sometimes things go violent
and sometimes they don't.
So how do you predict that? And if
you're unsure, which you will be,
how do you protect yourself first and
give yourself the maximum amount of time
to make a judgment call
so you don't have to rush
on top of that.
Yeah,
it's awesome that you're doing Jujitsu.
Do Boxing,
do Moitai do wrestling.
So you get used to getting hit.
So you start to see what a person's face
looks like when they're about to hit
you. So you start to see
what changes in their, their,
their, their posture makes when
they're about to throw a punch.
Those are all things that will help view.
Jujitsu is obviously
great for the grinding,
physical grappling situation, but
a lot of times, hopefully as a cop,
most of the time you're not in that
situation. You're standing at a little
bit of a distance and or
you're, you know, you're,
you've got a little
bit more time to judge.
So fight as much as you can.
Watch those law enforcement
and military videos again,
see the reactions, see the noise,
see the fear, see that panic,
look at people's eyes, judge them,
predict what they're going to do.
Press pause and figure out if you will,
right or wrong,
watch horrible violence happen so that
you can understand it better so that you
can handle it when the time arises.
Yeah.
O and m and just kind of to add on
some of the stuff you're saying,
I wouldn't even say compete if you can.
Cause a lot of times
in training you can't,
especially if you're training every day
or pretty often you can get into the
mindset that I can just train casual
today. And if a guy taps me out,
which everyone says it doesn't matter
that much. You know, so when you compete,
that's, that's one of the
significant things that I got. Um,
of that I realized when I was
competing. It's your, your re,
your senses are heightened because
everything matters. If you get taken down,
it matters. If you go for a submission
and you don't get it, it matters in,
in competition. So you have
that, that mindset more so,
and you'll get used to that mindset.
And to your point,
I tell this guy's at Jujitsu,
when you're training for a competition,
no matter what we do,
just about no matter 98% of the time I
can't get two guys in training to go as
hard against each other as
they're going to in competition.
As someone when someone gets a
grip of your g and competition.
Yeah it is 10 times stronger
than it is when you're training.
Cause if you rip,
if I go to grab your g color and you go
through some effort to rip it away and
we're training,
I'm going to let it go because I don't
care if it happens in competition and I
only have seven minutes to
work and get you submitted,
I'm going to hang on to that thing and
I'm going to hang onto it hard. Yeah.
And I'm not going to let go. And
so you end up with a much, much,
much more intense seven minutes in a
competition or three minutes in a boxing
sparring match or,
or an a Moitai the intensity.
You cannot simulate the intensity in co
in training that you're going to get in
competition.
And take that one step further.
When you get into a
life and death struggle,
you're going to have the same level of
jump to the intensity that's going to be
there. So that's a good
point as well. Yeah.
In that kind of goes from Moitai as well.
I'm not even necessarily
saying competing Moitai,
but when we ties a good one because you
get cracked in your body and your legs
and you get to feel some pain. Um,
and if you're not used to that.
Okay. Before I even started, when we,
today I went in, um, remember Terry,
so could you, he was like, Hey, you know,
we, we've trained you do two together.
There was like, Hey, I'm training
MMA today. Come, let's spar with me.
My other partners are doing.
And I was like, Hey, I don't
have any striking threes.
It's like, oh, I don't care, you
know, Jujitsu. So just train with me.
So proud. He punched me in the face
really hard and those, you know,
and I was like, man, just how you're
talking about this crash grenades.
Before it was kind of like that.
Just the fact that I got piped in,
knocked me out. It didn't days meet in
that way. It was just the fact that Dang,
I wasn't used to this.
I didn't know he was just going to
start punching me in my face. You know,
I thought we were just going to warm up.
So that's actually the main thing that
made me go into more type of specifically
to be used to getting cracked. Yeah.
Cause I was like, Bro, I'm not even,
I would thought I was pretty good
at Jujitsu. So I figured, you know,
like oh solid. You know, but brands,
so what if I get into some thing,
you know, outside of the
gym, the Guy Cracks me in my
face and I'm not used to it.
Yeah. You know, so meant, so the,
what the movies I did help is
when you get hit in the face,
it's like Jujitsu,
someone grinding on you and they're
breathing all in your nose or they're
sweating all in your eye or whatever.
That doesn't bother you at all.
You barely notice it introduced.
It doesn't matter. Right.
So the same thing with [inaudible].
When you get punched in the nose and it's
bleeding and you see your own blood or
whatever, but if you're not used
to that yet, that'll mess you up.
If you notice back in the day,
like they're old UFC or whatever,
guys will get cracked in the face like
three, four times hard and they'll be,
oh tap, holy cow. You know, cause
they're just not used to it.
Nowadays guys are just, they
won't, they won't talk. Yeah,
the referee got to start on it and they're
used to it rarely does anyone tapped
in the UFC from strikes.
Very rare.
Unless they're like
injured even then it won't.
Probably Laurie Mcdonald did know.
Yeah. So anyway, so, so the point is,
so when we tie situation in specific,
because that's where you feel the
most pain, like more than boxing,
like even even,
I mean you'll take brain injury for sure,
but it's not actual paint and we take it
kicked in the leg and they teach you to
hide the pain and to not let it affect
you and go in the end in the ribs like
body, like needs to the ribs. It's
super painful when you get used to that.
I think doubt out cause like if you're in
a situation, the streets on the cracks,
you hard in the face.
You know what's interesting about that
though is that there are some people that
can,
can easily or more easily take
the pain of Moy Thai or boxing.
Like it's okay with them then.
Then they,
then they can take the grind of Jujitsu
and some people can take the grind of
Jujitsu all day long,
but they can never take the striking pain.
So it's, there's just some
genetic or mental situations.
But to your point,
you need to be comfortable
with both of those situations.
And at the very least just familiar
with it. Oh, I'd like I said,
that first punch that I took
in my face and granted it was,
I wasn't ready for him to just wail on
me like that played football too. Yeah.
I mean so you've been hit, you've been
knocked out before on the field. Right.
So it's, it's kind of it. If
I were to try to remember it,
it was a combination of
sure that physical impact,
but just the fact that this guy just
punched me in my face right now.
Like it's always like Dang to discus
punch me in my base right now.
We're going to, yeah, I
ain't like that. But yeah,
after a while it doesn't mean the hardest
I ever got punched in the face was
from Greg right in the like right between
my eyes. And it was like happenstance.
He threw a real solid one.
Um,
as I went to kind of shoot who's kind
of coming up off his knees kind of,
and I went to shoot like I got,
I got from off my back and then forward
in shot forward and he just went boom.
And the,
the,
the force of me shooting forward and
then pull and I felt it in my neck is
really bad. But it was in a hard
part, lucky in code. But yeah,
fully that was a Kale Punch.
She just happened to be in
that really hard part. Um,
but I had been through that before.
I train Muay Thai before and it didn't,
it didn't even slow me down.
I remember thinking that was probably
the hardest punch I ever took.
And news with the MMA glove. It wasn't
with a big boxing gloves. Oh yeah.
Back in the old days,
we used to just spark or full on
with MMA gloves on a regular basis.
Yes. Stupid. Yeah. And, but
don't do that folks. Yeah, yeah.
Don't do that.
There's the whole deal.
But what I'm saying is that [inaudible]
good again, I was used to it.
It didn't slow me down.
If that was like a situation where I took
that kind of hard hit in a, you know,
or a cop would take that kind of hard
hit and they're used to that in training
or whatever,
that's not going to slow them down.
That's not going to stun them unless it
physically stuns them on the jars to me.
Yeah. And that's, you know, even if you're
trained, that's, that's, that's gonna.
That's gonna January fact,
if you train too much and you
get yourself hit too often,
you'll actually decrease your
ability to withstand punishment.
So careful about that. You want to
train enough that you're used to it,
you want to know that you can take it,
but then you don't want
to overtrain at all. Yeah.
You never get better it take,
well, no, let me rephrase that.
You get better at taking punches for a
short period of time and then it goes,
starts to go backwards. You know, and
unfortunately that's just the way the uh,
the body's built.
And you can see as some of the
older UFC fighters get older,
you know, there's no doubt they don't
have the chin that they once had.
And that's when they usually
decide to hang it up. Or if they,
if they get the right counsel from people.
But nowadays people are sparring a lot
less and they're trying to not take all
that punishment because everyone
realizes that you have a,
you have a limited number
of hits you can take to the,
to the head and then it starts to
go backwards. And it's, you know,
a lot of this information is coming
from the dupe soldiers overseas,
the marines overseas that have taken
concussions and IED strikes and they're
realizing that that is a permanent,
you know,
downgrade of their systems and
they, they, you know, so they,
so they, that's where a lot of this
information came from about football,
this concussion stuff in football.
A lot of that is coming from the,
the Iud is that our soldiers and marines
if taken overseas and they've realized
that this traumatic trauma,
traumatic brain injury is problematic.
And so we need to, we need
to watch out for it. So yeah,
especially if you're being a
cop and you gotta be alert.
But that's why I like the way I like the
Muy Thai. That's why I personally I did,
because it was a lot of like
clenching needs in those, if you, if,
if you've never done it,
you would think they'd been punched in
the nose square in the nose real hard
would be probably one of
the more painful things,
but it wasn't compared to
the ribs and the legs, man.
So if you're kind of used to just
taking impacts and pain, yeah. You just,
you just, not to mention the physical
part, but just mentally, they're like,
when that,
when that comes about,
you can just just keep on keeping on now
cause you're used to it or you're gone
to the moon from inoculate,
inoculate yourself, not Kulish.